here's a look at logan gilbert's season
stats this is his 19th start of the
season 544 era the 5-5 record 86 innings
97 strikeouts only 20 walks
we tapper logan
on the third base side throws a fastball
to first base and altuve is retired
here's michael brantley
that ball up the middle over the head
just beyond the outstretched glove of jp
crawford michael brantley after the off
day comes right back with a base hit and
steps jordan alvarez with two ounces and
a man aboard jenna swing and a miss and
a breaking ball that was down for strike
three and that's going to retire the
side strikeout number one for logan
gilbert jake odorizzi is on the mound
for the houston astros he is two and one
this season against the mariners last
time out august 21st he was a recipient
of all those runs did a good job going
five and two thirds against east seattle
mariners striking out eight and only
allowing one earned run
that was right down the middle a 2-2
fastball taken for a called third strike
two up and two down for kyle seeger
that ball popped in the air long run for
bregman he's the only one that can get
there and he does in pal territory
michael with a big smile for him as he
made the adjustment late alex bregman a
nice play to end the inning here's alex
bregman fragment back in there
back-to-back games in seattle six for 17
since coming off the injured list as
bregman drills one to center field
following quickly and that's in front of
jared kellnick alex bregman continues to
hit well coming off the il seven for 18.
two outs pregnant at first jake myers
rookie center fielder batting swing and
a miss got him with a breaking ball for
strike three that's going to retire the
side strikeout number two for logan
gilbert jacob rizzi spun a one two three
first inning he faces ty france
okay
and right away he is on base first pitch
he sees
sees him and he continues to add on to
his record which he set last night the
last two pitches thrown at ty francis
hit him oh tie on at first base he's all
right here's abraham toro the star of
last night's game and that is thrown
behind them
mariners have two on it appears as
though odorizi
lost his footing kind of checks his feet
after
he delivers the pitch mariners have
runners on it first and second with
nobody out that'll bring up left fielder
jose mar malayos
foul tip caught by maldonado there's the
second strikeout for odarizi and a big
first down here in the second inning
with runners on first and second now
louise terence bats
bobbled by orisi a couple of times
almost picks up the rosin bag
right there in the neighborhood terence
is out has the effect of the sack bun as
he moves france into third and toro
to second two one and two outs and
that'll bring up center fielder jared
kelnick
called third strike or just pump it down
the middle oh to rizzy strands runners
on second and third so the astros now
with two shutout innings today so
they're now on a 12 inning scoreless
streak altuve and company would like to
get that turned around here
that ball hit well to left field going
back onto marmalajo so it'll bounce off
the wall and over his head altuve can
trot into second base with a one out
double jose altuve with the first extra
base hit of the game for the astros
here's correa runner on third two out
fastball swung on hit to jp on the
backhand down to his knee steps up
throws two hopper dug out by ty france
beautifully done by the gold glove
shortstop jp crawford well done he nips
his counterpart and the astros strand a
runner on third base i'll bring up mitch
haniger flying out the right center
field his first time up
swing and a miss fastball up odor rizzio
one two three inning he's retired six in
a row scoreless tie as we go to the top
of the fourth jordan alvarez the lead
off swing anime city got him strike
three
second time that gilbert has fanned your
don alvarez that is strikeout number
three for logan gilbert the wind-up fan
the 2-2 to alex swinging a fly ball into
straight away center field drifting back
as jared kelneck he's there waits looks
into that bright sunshine and he makes
the catch and that'll end the inning
nice job again by logan gilbert so far
pretty good pitchers duel third baseman
kyle seeger lays things off
got him breaking ball seeger swings on
top of it odor izzy with five strikeouts
in the first out of the fourth just a
little bit of a hiccup in that second
inning with a hit batter and a walk but
other than that jake has looked very
good france was hit by a pitch as last
time swung on hard hit ground ball right
back up the middle rammed into center
field and ty france gets aboard with one
out here in the bottom of the fourth
inning he is something and the mariners
have their first hit of the game off of
botories and it comes with one out here
in the fourth here's left fielder jose
mar meleos go ahead run on it second
with two outs fastball got him strike
three in her third marmalajos goes down
six strikeout for oda rizzy we played
four
trying to solve logan gilbert they did
last time around kind of punished him in
mid-may park but today a different story
the 3-2 pitch swung on fly ball right
field down the line and toward the
corner over hannigar on the run running
out of room near the wall leaps up and
he makes the catch
holy smokes what a catch by mitch
haniger he was running out of room in
that right field corner at the end of
the run a little leap at the top of the
fence right near the foul pole nice play
by mid so one away and that'll bring up
center fielder jake myers the wind up
and the 3-2 swing enemy strike three
their strikeout number four for logan
gilbert left-hander justice sheffield
will come out of the bullpen for the
very first time went on the il with that
strained left elbow and the strained
oblique infield hit for correa who now
has a game hitting streak and now jordan
alvarez will try and snap an 0 for eight
in the series in on his hands pull to
toro right side throw over to seeger for
one back to first double play
four
five
three double play odor rizzy threw five
with a one hit shutout nobody out
crawford at first
and he takes
two one nobody out so the walk the
second walk of the game allowed by odor
izzy he's also allowed two hits but he
will come out of the game here with 87
pitches on his ledger and phil maton
will be the new pitcher two on and
nobody out and here's kyle seeger
froze him with a fastball seeger doesn't
like the call but that's his strike
zigger down on strikes and the mariners
have him loaded again for toro game
winning grand slam last night you can
hear the buzz in the crowd here first
pitch to toro
soft fly ball medium depth myers now in
shadow left center crawford coming home
j.p crawford is on his way and he scores
standing over the last two games it is
now toro five
and the astros nothing abraham turo gets
the job done again for the mariners and
they have a one-nothing lead two outs
here in the sixth so the runner to third
now with two outs he's gonna go to the
pen here with a runner on third base and
two out a one-o count on j.p crawford
and he hits one high in the air popped
up
behind home plate martine maldonado in
the shadows puts it away for the final
out of the inning big out there for
blake taylor strand to run around third
base fires the runner on first base now
pinch hitter for the astros they lift
martine maldonado and they put in oledmi
diaz having a really strong season
on the ground to crawford toro right
there on to first base plenty of time
for the double play the astros with a
walk and a single with two out
right-hander paul seawall will take over
and relieve first and second for carlos
correa frank three called on the outside
corner he got him with a fast ball and
paul seawall does what he does best 18
straight innings of scoreless baseball
from one of the best offenses in all of
the major leagues jordan alvarez facing
paul seawalled here leading off the
ninth with the astros trailing one to
nothing oh two
strike three
call seawall strikes out your don
alvarez looking facing julie guriel
he only shoots one into right field that
is a nice job by julie guriel down in
the count battling and ending up with a
single to right tying run as a board go
ahead come into the plate now one out
one on a one run game for bregman
alex on the ground that's gonna be a
base hit pass to diving crawford into
left field astros in business tying run
on second go ahead run on first
got action and now it's kyle tucker's
turn he is over three today tying run in
scoring position for the astros
popped him up
crawford
racing out dylan moore coming in two
away
the astros rookie batting with two outs
and two on in a one-nothing mariners
ball game in the ninth inning everybody
up on their feet now now the payoff
strike three cold that's the ball game
for the first time since 2016
the mariners pitch back to back shutouts
and this time it comes against the
houston astros
[Applause]